the red bricks of this midlands town
represent the first line of defense of
what was the red wall
ashfield is one of the many traditional
labour strongholds that turned blue in
the 2019 general election but a new poll
of the 57 so-called red wall
constituencies shows that labour are
once again in favor in these vital seats
it's whoever gets in it's it's hard in
tech whether it's labour or conservative
they've all got a hard job to do you
know so i mean people are calling doris
this that but i think no matter who took
the job
they've still got a odd job to do when
it comes to voting again i think a lot
of seats in this especially in bats law
bassett law and nottinghamshire
derbyshire will definitely go back to
being labour which way would you vote
that's what i mean i don't know because
i don't know who does what what
the mp here is former minor lee anderson
he's one of 20 tory mps and peers
turning up the heat on the government to
tackle the rise in energy bills by
removing vat and environmental levies
we're very concerned you know to come
out the pandemic obviously there's a
greater demand for fuel
and at the moment demand is outstripping
supply so obviously prices aren't going
to go up but that's of little comfort to
people that live in this area ashfield
and eastwood they see the fuel fields
going up
the wages aren't going up quite as quick
they're genuinely worried how they're
going to pay the electric bill are they
going to pay the gas bill and now
they're going to keep their houses warm
on the other side of the fire in the
doghouse pub are alan and debra he's a
plaster boarder she's a nurse neither
are looking forward to more price hikes
my direct debit has gone up from like
probably 55 pounds a month it's gone up
to 80 something which
no fault of hours it's just just one of
those things that's just happened and we
just have to sort of accept it we're now
getting it one two and i don't put it on
until about four till before deborah
comes in whereas before i didn't need to
turn it straight on so it's an extra
jumper on
as wholesale gas prices increased by 500
in a year domestic fuel costs went up in
october and they'll go up again in april
we will have seen the price of heating
your home double in 18 months and if the
worst aspects of the analyst projections
are right we'll see energy bills double
in a very short period of time and it's
going to be pretty catastrophic for
millions of households
sleaze and controversy often don't
affect the way people vote but when the
electorates are hit in the pocket that
might just be enough to change the color
of the bricks in this political wall
back to red
fraser moored sky news ashfield